I have been waiting so long for this
Alida battle angel first trailer has
just hit I didn't even realize this
trailer was about to come out but oh
okay before I get into the trailer
itself a little bit of background with
me on this I discovered I know it as
battle angel Aleta that I discovered
that through the anime I think it's
called an OVA it's kind of a short film
it's it's not really feature like but I
caught that on I think it was something
like stars like maybe around 2000 or so
and then in back in 2003 it was
confirmed that James Cameron had the
rights and was working on the movie it
was supposed to be his next movie after
like his latest underwater documentary
thing and then it got put on hold for
him to make avatar and then when he was
done Avatar he was supposed to come back
to this and then he was making avatar 2
3 4 5 so I've had a lot of frustration
for how long this has been delayed and
that eventually landed in the hands of
Robert Rodriguez as a director with
James Cameron as a producer now on paper
I like this a lot Rodriguez is a
director I admire a lot but he can kind
of unless I go off the rails but he's
very insular he's very into doing his
own thing in his own thing sometimes
works better than others but I think
combining him with James Cameron and I
think he I think Cameron can help temper
some of Rodriguez's more sort of
rapid-fire to the point of just being
annoying storytelling instincts and also
help him ensure that it's gonna have
better effects cuz Rodriguez does like
to do his effects in-house and sometimes
settle for less than great but so the
two of them together on this property I
love that so the trailer itself has a
mix of reactions from me I think I guess
I'll start with the elephant in the room
which I'm pretty sure I haven't looked
at other people's reactions of this
thing I usually don't before show these
videos but I suspect it's gonna be the
eyes on Aleta herself
they're off-putting but that kind of
works it's one of those things that like
I can't decide where to land because my
gut reaction is at odds with my
intellectual reaction because my gut
reaction is uh that's uncanny valley and
weird and off-putting but then my
intellectual reaction is well yeah she's
not human she's an she's an ant not only
is she not human
she's an ant she's a robot she's a
machine so the fact that she is built to
look like a human but exists in the
uncanny valley kind of makes sense
in addition doing the really big eyes
more than just being any kind of a nod
to the anime actually shows a really
practical function which is that the
rest of the things that give her away as
being robotic you know the arm a lot of
her torso whatever that can be covered
with clothing the eyes that can't the
eyes immediately give her away so she
can't hide and people will immediately
look at her and know immediately what
she is and I think that can also lend
itself really well to the storytelling
but like I said I am sort of fighting my
visceral reactions so intellectually I
can justify that this looking on candy
Valley is fine kind of much in the same
way that I can justify how clue looked
in Tron Legacy because he was a computer
program it's okay that he looks not
quite right so I can justify it that way
I do kind of lingeringly wonder if it's
just gonna make it hard for audiences to
connect with her properly as a character
if if you know they if they get a
lingering shot looking into those eyes
and they don't make the connection that
you do with a good human actor instead
they just kind of go yeah that's my one
potential concern as far as that goes
initially I was kind of wondered and you
know thinking yo is it done um but I
think it is I think it probably is I
know some people say you shouldn't judge
effects of a trailer they're not done
yet there's more time to fix them and I
will grant that that's true but at the
same time in my mind if you're gonna put
an effect in the trailer it better be
done because you only have one chance to
make a first impression
so it's one of two things it either
done this is how it looks or it's not
done and you blew your first impression
in which case you're going about your
marketing very stupidly at the very
least so I think it's perfectly fair to
judge all of these these graphics and
and to assume that they that what we see
is finished this is what the finished
product will look like
so aside from that this thing does a lot
of things that I have a tendency to not
if not rail against at least call out
his red flags at least for me in this
case though they really made me smile
instead so like the plot or the beats we
get in the characters we see them like I
know all these characters and it does
feel like it is setting up very much to
tell that first that story of the first
volume of battle angel Aleta the of the
manga which the OVA was was adapted from
so that it really does feel very much
lifted from that and that should annoy
me I mean I'm the guy who says if you're
literally just gonna tell the same story
again don't do it do something else do
some changes do something to validate
the fact that you're expecting me to see
something that I already know the plot
to and yet it's not triggering that in
me and I'm I'm not sure if that has to
do with like the trailer doing it really
well or just more having to do with my
own connection to this property because
more so than like say ghost in the
shell' where I did a lot of complaining
even before the movie came out seeing
like this all looks near visually looks
directly lifted these are all huge red
flags for me but comparing the two part
of why I was extremely skeptical of
ghost in the shell' as a live action
movie again even well before it came out
was because I didn't think it could
possibly be better than the original
animated feature I just didn't and in
the case of battle angel as much as I
love that OVA
it's not even feature-length so the
thing that initially made me fall in
love with this property is something
that also at the same time left me
wanting more I remember how
incredibly disappointed I was after
catching that thing on TV and realizing
it's not part of a series there is it a
sequel there isn't more what so maybe
the fact that I've literally been left
wanting more for almost two decades on
this property may be that sort of
tempers my usual instincts to complain
about how it looks like you're basically
just doing the same story that doesn't
necessarily remove the criticism I think
if anyone wanted to make that criticism
from what we can tell from this trailer
it'd be a perfectly valid one it's just
I need to acknowledge that for me in
this specific case I'm willing to
overlook it which I will freely
acknowledge usually I can't I'm human
I'm not a machine
I don't always go exactly according to
logic and precedent that I've already
said emotional gut reactions are a weird
thing but I love the cast in this I
don't know Rosa Salazar I don't know her
at all but the rest of them Christoph
Waltz he's always good even well even in
almost always good he wasn't good
inspector but everything was wrong with
that character but he's pretty much
always good he was even good in Green
Hornet so I'm really excited about him
Jennifer Connelly is an actress who
doesn't always do much for me but I know
what character she's play and I love
that match and my her Sheila alley
first of all phenomenal actors second of
all I know again I know that character
is playing and I'm immediately going oh
yes yes this is gonna be great and you
know you know the views of the of that
higher sort of city that's above this
junkyard and the visuals feel really
good like I said aside from like pretty
much all my concerns that that wouldn't
be the ones that I should have ie it
looks like it's telling the same story
all my lingering concerns have to do
with the visuals which is that I it's a
lot of CG and it looks like CG which can
take me out of movie sometimes and we'll
see how it pans out I mean it can work a
lot of it has to do with just how well
the film visually establishes its
reality cuz I can buy CG unfortunately
you know things like Aleta herself and
some of the other characters that we see
moving around they
are made to look more human than I think
is ideal for when you're making
something that heavy on CG because I
mean the more human you design a
creature or anything you know that
you're using CG for just the tougher it
is to have it work and nail it and I
think that's a big part of why something
like avatar you know visually from a
visual perspective looks fine because
they are human enough for you to connect
but they're also disconnected enough
from looking human that you don't pick
apart when the when the CGI isn't
perfect or like an I think an even
better example of that district 9 the
the Pras looked amazing and the guy and
it's not that the technology was any
better than what's happening what's been
going on since it's just that our brain
doesn't have to reference it to a to
what we know humans look like and
because you know our brain does that
automatically whether we wanted to or
not and so we pick at every little thing
that we see that is a little bit off so
given some of the characters I'm seeing
that that uncanny valley thing is
something that worries me a little but
again I may be able to sort of roll with
it on the basis of well these are
Androids they're not totally human in
the first place so I can kind of deal
with the fact that they look a little
off because they're a little off to me
maybe they're a little off to the people
who are living with them so then it just
becomes a matter of it still looks like
it exists in that space cuz to me
there's kind of two elements to the
whole uncanny valley valley think
there's the general look does it look
wrong which again in this case they kind
of do but in the case of Aleta at least
deliberately so so I can kind of work
with that but then the second piece of
that doesn't look like it was just copy
pasted into a picture or does it look
like it actually existed in that space
and that has a lot to do with shot
composition and getting the lightning
right in the rendering and how the
actors respond to it and that's
something that the trailer alone can't
really convince me of it doesn't have
the time to do it because you generally
need just more time existing in the
space to figure out whether or not
that's going to work but yeah
battling Julita I
I knew the movie was coming out it is
honestly one of my most anticipated
movies of next year and I didn't know
the trailer was coming out so to be
surprised by seeing that come up in my
feed click on it and get to see that and
see these actors in these roles know how
good a fit they are for these characters
yeah that puts a big grin on my face
even though I've still got reservations
and even though I freely acknowledge a
lot of what's going on here stuff that I
have complained about before but in this
case it's just not bugging me sometimes
that happens so Elita battle angel first
trailer did you see it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
were drop something down on the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that is
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio
I am also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast that's a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast comm links for all this
stuff is down below and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]